let's talk about ugly dude a game that
keeps on giving yeah man especially this
time around no hoops so basketball
basically has been brought to the world
of speedy and tinky racecars the ice
hockey update I feel like I was well
back in November or something it was
like a little bit and that's kind of fun
it was like a nice changeup yeah it was
i got christmas-themed what I were like
throw it in there come yeah never really
play it this is like a dedicated group
of people they seem to always be playing
it yeah and everybody jump in there this
on the other hand it's like totally
change the game yeah it's great it's
really great and I it makes me really
excited because it's it's you know I
think we all go on like a little bit
with winds of like when we gonna we're
going to play a lot of rocket League
maybe take a break play something else
this time it's like 110 percent I want
to play this like all damn day play like
four hours last night yeah first time I
really I kind of play like every like I
feel like I play like 30 minutes every
day yeah or 30 minutes every two days to
my cash yeah but this was like all in so
let's talk about the details I guess
Mike you played a bunch is about right
yeah all right so this is 2 v2
predominantly online yeah yeah you can
do for before like just private match if
you want to that gets just like it does
in soccer it gets kind of hectic yeah
but also more dangerous though just
because the ball like any times in the
area you're kind of [ __ ] your pants
mmm I I imagine in for before stuff it's
probably a bit more like chaotic the
goals like the goal is just come from
nowhere from like a rebound I came from
nowhere I don't did we even try 44 yeah
we think we did we did toward the end
because we had before like people left
the office 3v3 and it was just pretty
much the coroner game in the hoops now
is really important because can get
those layup goals or the bank goals and
just people just collide left and right
in the corners now like mainly my own
teammates but I can feel like it was
great it was up that it was like playing
rocket League week one again where
nobody knows what to do so everyone's
kind of like rushing into the coroner's
it's not like now I don't even bother
now it's like unless I get that shot off
the corner where bounces and goes in
it's like there's no point in jumping in
there unless you're getting boost so i
guess like the first couple of hours was
like how does this work how do you score
what is the best way of like centering
what is the best way rob one of you sort
of what's your takeaway after playing
this for
a day and change of like the new tactics
that you kind of need to use it sure
this one yeah no longer I feel are you
slamming this ball as hard as you can
yeah because all that's going to do is
shoot the ball and ricochet back under
your side so you're taking your time uh
and more or less and too BTW i think
they really know this because to be to
work so well because you're really just
playing off your one other teammate
you're one of you is just simply trying
to pop the ball up and then the other
ones trying to slam dunk yeah so you and
when it comes to also dunking and
popping it up is you really have to
feather it again you you are not hitting
this ball with all your might you're
just kind of a little too flip tap tap
it in get it up and then someone else
will uh yeah just slam dunk that thing
yeah it's too hard to get the dunk if
the ball is flying around at speed in
the air yeah so you're just not really
doing yourself any favors yeah
absolutely so in in that respect it's
very much an aerial game you're trying
to get that that flood that pop fly
before anyone else um but yeah like it
again I mean this is always kind of been
with rocket League two is you're not
like both rushing the ball like I i was
even played I think also 44 is really
frustrating because this map size isn't
spectacularly large right it's not if
anything it might be even shorter than
most I think it is a cancer it feels
like it's about maybe maybe it's like
eighty percent or seventy percent the
size of rice feel there's something but
yeah it's something about the the ball
feels like a moves differently to like
it's kinda more like that definitely
flow dear yeah I at first like when we
all play in the office really this I
wish this was bigger the arena but the
more I played I played a little bit last
night not as much I'd like to afterward
or after we all left the office and I'm
actually I think the size is really good
I mean if it was bigger you would score
so much less frequently yeah totally
because it's such a it's such a
concentrated goal because I mean the
goals themselves weren't huge in soccer
and now now there's just so many like
less chances of going in because it's
this hovering you know target and some
great little touches well they're adding
the this is obviously a free update for
everyone who's got rocket League they're
adding the dlc NBA flags which i think
is every single team in the tournament I
thought sorry in the NBA the 30 30
I think you have to pay for those quad
yes you have to pay for those oh yeah
that's the only part yeah that's that's
a--that's paid for DLC and but does look
like they did a really good job of like
I'm adding nice little touches to this
Oh like a static later and the like the
squeaks or is so it's landing after a
layup or anything like that like your
hand brake slide and getting ready for
any kind of set yeah it's it's really
fun even even the sound effect on the
rim of the hoop oh yeah really great
yeah it like I could just confidently
say it's like a plastic with like a
little bit of rattling like metal inside
it like really full I don't pop it off a
kind of yeah you also really like that
whenever the ball is hovering above the
target zone it'll glow like origami so
it helps you know when when it's still
like in danger of when you need to save
it or when you could possibly go for a
dunk because like it's floating over
your blue it's floating over the other
goals to honor either it grows more blue
or orange together and then when it's
almost there it's sort of it's almost
like pulsating or hate and then does it
go lately colored when it's when it's I
think yeah yeah yeah like the primary
tone of it I think definitely like
shifts to that but if we can talk about
men if you're playing defense and you
see the thing and it is you're looking
up and you know prior to rocket League
you basically get like a 180 opportunity
right if this ball is coming down from
the top all you gotta do is just hit it
in a general direction against the wall
and you're good it's gonna head shot
yeah just jump up here you got like a
360 degrees so your car you know you're
like like we were swearing I especially
it was swearing so often because you
just you can't find the right angle hmm
uh and you of course you want to like
you want a hit an aerial and go straight
up but or like it not not directly up
because then it's gotta come straight
back down again as well as sometimes
you're right like just go like right
it's socially it's I want to go back to
playing the regular sock armos just to
be like see all the terrible things that
I've learned from playing this
basketball version yeah cuz it totally
changes how you get into it and the tip
offs then they're all completely
different too yeah right the tip offs uh
I think we mentioned a lil bit earlier
when we're talking Danny is it's kind of
cool because if this were to come out
you know two months after a rocket
League where people are worth like
definitely still learning how to do the
aerial moves yeah I think kickoffs
tip-offs where this would just been so
frustrating but you have to have a
somewhat decent aerial player to hit it
first because if you don't hit it first
and some the other team does it's gonna
go in yeah now they've gotten to say to
her like give them six hours and
everyone's like okay I can score from
right okay yes to things like if this
had come out two months after release
Pete Brown would have gotten like
destroyed but yesterday he was the one
like on the tip-off he had the most days
out of any of us here area like down pat
and he was just that perfect angle where
you kind of tip Chris waters is saying
like no you were saying if the kind of
hitter with the windshield to get the
right actually I haven't yeah it's
probably like a load of different ways
you can do it he was nailing every time
then one thing Rob got really good at
which reminded me of how like actual
basketball is played is when it's like
rolling off the rim Rob head the aerial
like angled down so he kind of just give
it a tip back in on ice yeah awful tough
yeah it's so sad of something when it
works at yeah you can do all this stuff
as well in exhibition modes you can do
what BOTS although the bots do not know
what the hell's going on super funny I
mean whoever plays Exhibition Mode you
know like i just did just a practice
that there's a bas he'll just drive into
it's like it's super funny they just
weren't ever programmed to jump on on
the beginning of around so they all just
collide yet when you I was doing
one-on-one with it as well and the other
BOTS was just basically sitting in the
net like whenever I went in there half
as if they're standing on the goal line
I think so it's good to like you know
learn a bit of fundamentals or you know
just practice a little bit yeah it's
great though I last point on it's okay
so some nice little sort of quality of
life fixes as well they've they've put
in like the ability to save replays kind
of like quick say like hot saved yeah
something so during a match you can I
think you hit like for PlayStation 4's
you know it's just like your general
touchpad you hit that and it'll it'll
message will pop and be like oh we are
going to automatically save this replay
for you because you want that and then
the other options is after your match
ends a message comes up in it's like
what do you on to name this which is
really great if you eventually just like
me at least called one like Chris eat
[ __ ] or something but Jay you end up
with like this massive
just you know you know all this is like
june fifth who are you lost due to one
it's I don't remember that am i right in
saying that the new camera they like the
little pop soon on the replay is new as
well oh that's so real that that's just
so reminiscent of an agilent yeah may I
guess any kind of sports stream but it
just reminds me exactly of basketball
you know after a three good like I
always do the floor yeah is it only
basketball no I mean I guess no no I
mean have they only put it in the bus
yeah that's that's definitely new it's
nobody eyes anyone got my actually
played soccer yet oh I say in my right
side of that if they did or not yeah I
don't know it's so lame the both of us
for life do another weird watch yo Bodie
I guess that's basketball right yeah
definitely well walking better looking
backwards you're curious i have the
court that's good stuff yeah i'm on ah
alright there you go that's it it's free
it's available forever now they're kind
of rolling it out last night over all
the platforms and whatnot yeah if you
have this on xbox one or ps4 RPC